so hello everyone and welcome to our
workshop I'm so thrilled this is so many
of you here as I was joking about before
I only saw like six forks in a
repository and I was thinking that's
gonna be a small crowd so I'm so happy
to see so many I'm Elena and we have
shishun as well and we're from the
Cambridge coding Academy and today our
workshop is going to be focusing on what
makes a good model and how can you
distinguish it from a one-hit wonder and
what kind of tips and tricks we can
teach you in order to make your model
better and improve its performance so
just a brief agenda of what we will be
covering today the first session is
going to be a little bit of me doing the
talking so it's going to be a little bit
of the theory in the background so we're
going to introduce important machine
learning techniques such as overfitting
and the balance of variants trade-off
and we're going to introduce many
different validation techniques discuss
their advantages and disadvantages and
compare them one with one another and
see the potential application so where
would you choose each particular
technique to use then the second part is
more hands-on more interactive so you
can choose to work independently but we
really like to group people up we like a
lot of the programming happiness going
on so if you want to find a per body to
work with that's a lot more fun you can
exchange ideas and work in pairs if you
want and in this session we will be
covering a simplistic model so canine
classifiers and we get to learn how to
tune the parameters for this model and
visualize the results along the way and
for the third session we're going to
step it up a little bit and cover more
advanced models again see how we can
tune this up and evaluate their
performance and compare them with one
another so by the end of the day we hope
that you can be able to determine
somehow the goodness of a clever
classification model and comprehend why
validation is so crucial when it comes
to working with this very powerful black
boxes and I can't stress enough
how people tend to avoid and skip
completely validation leading to super
optimistic results which in the end when
it's time to apply to new data you get
very poor quality results and you're
stuck there thinking hmm what have I
done wrong last but not least we're
going to see some very good practices in
machine learning through throughout the
whole tutorial but for our toy data set
for the day we get to work with the
publicly available breast cancer data
set from the University of California
for those of you that are interested in
to finding finding some freely available
data sets this is a very good resource
to use it has a lot of the popular
machine learning data sets such as the
iris data set if you want to play around
with and in this particular study this
is a real world case study and it
contains 569 samples so 569 patients
have provided samples and it contains
measurements of 30 measurements in this
case of features such as the radius and
the perimeter of of a particular sample
specialized people with specially have
categorized these samples into two
distinct categories which are benign and
malignant samples and this is in machine
learning what we call a binary case
scenario because we're working with two
different independent classes so once we
get to load our data into our ipython
notebook this is somehow how it's going
to look like and it's our job as data
scientists to be able to decipher this
information into our infuse it into our
prediction model now once we have our
data it's always a very good practice
and it's always very wise to start by
somehow plotting your data and having a
look and feel of the background of your
data the presence you can choose to see
independently one feature at a time by
using something like a histogram so in
this
case I can investigate the radios and we
can see that of course that for
malignant cases the radius expands over
larger and wider ranges than the benign
samples and that's something to be
expected and you can also choose to plot
one feature against another so this is a
unique variant type of plotting and this
is a good approach because from this
plotting you can see some sort of
overlap so it can give you a good idea
of how well can I separate my data
should I go for a linear model which is
something very simplistic or should I go
for something more advanced like a
nonlinear model and we can see that in
this case there's quite some overlap so
it can be a first indication of the type
of model the type of complexity we would
like to use of course these are only two
features to randomly selected features
you can plot three dimensions or you can
see different combination of features at
a time and this will give you a further
more thorough idea but this is a first
step and it's quite advisable to do so
now today we will be focusing with
supervised learning techniques and in
particular classification models and in
our classification models we start by
having some prior knowledge so the idea
is like we want to train our model by
experience and in a way simulate the
human brain for us humans is very
intuitive to distinguish two animals
from one another a cat versus a dog and
why is that because we've spent our
whole lives being trained or being
taught how to distinguish the two based
on certain characteristics certain
measurements certain features and this
is exactly what we want to feed our
algorithm with this type of knowledge
prior knowledge in the form of data in
order to use this knowledge in order to
predict new unseen data so we start from
our input input matrix which always
contains row wise our samples and column
wise our features and in supervised
learning we have an associated an
associated vector of classes in this
case so we know for instance in the
scenario
we saw before that certain samples are
categorized as malignant and others are
categorized as benign so this is a prior
knowledge that we have and our purpose
is to build this prediction model which
is in the form of a mathematical
function and nothing else as a way of
predicting new unseen data so this is
exactly the type of approach we would
like to see so a common mistake that
people tend to do is train and test this
using exactly the same data set but with
prediction modeling is what how do we
determine a good model is by its
generalization performance so for a
generalization we don't mean how well it
performs on data we already know when we
already have but from a future unknown
data set that may appear at some point
in the future and we need to be able to
predict it quite well now this
generalization performance the metric
that we will be using menu today is the
overall maximum accuracy so how well how
many of our samples have been correctly
classified in which case we're talking
about the maximum accuracy or you can
choose to use the minimum error if you
want to but at the same time it's also
important to not only focus on the
overall accuracy but also focus on
metrics such as the sensitivity and
specificity and precision and Rico
because for instance let us think about
Amazon and a fraud detection team they
deal with transactions on a daily basis
that may have millions of transactions
happening within one day and they would
like to to be able to identify and to
support those transactions that are
illegitimate so those transactions that
haven't been made on purpose but they're
actually fraud and we can think that on
a daily basis this transaction ratio is
quite small in as opposed to the normal
transactions that people do so if we
think that our models train based on
this knowledge it may perform extremely
well by giving us an overall prediction
of 99 percent and we can walk away being
very happy and think that our models
really
good but does it actually predict the
class that we're really interested in is
our model biased again the majority
class and giving us a very good
indication about the normal transactions
is it able to predict this small subset
of data that belong in a fraud case or
not so there's there's this tendency in
order to get this maximum training
accuracy of scientists falling into a
very big mistake in machine learning and
that is overfitting overfitting is the
case whereby we're trying to build a
decision boundary and the decision
boundaries we can think it as the
geometric representation of our
prediction model so the idea is we build
this boundary and we want our classes to
fall on each side of the boundary and
there's this tendency in order to
produce this maximum accuracy we feed
our model with a lot of features at a
time and we tend to make it more and
more complicated by increasing the
degree in a polynomial or managing and
surrounding each one of the samples and
and by doing so by increasing the
complexity we end up with this let's say
this Green Line whereby you can see this
zigzag with many creases now in this
case the model will perform amazingly
well using the data that we already have
but because it captures noise and
because it's so specific and captures
independent individual samples at a time
when you throw new data at it it doesn't
know how to predict them and this is a
case of overfitting so potentially if we
were to use a different kind of decision
boundaries such as the black one it may
leave a few of the red samples fall on
the other side of the boundary by giving
us a slightly lower training accuracy
but it may generalize better so this is
how we determine that a good model is
actually fit in this case the opposite
case in this in this scenario is under
fitting under fitting is when our model
is too simplistic for the type of data
we're working with to actually give us a
good
addiction so in the case of other
underfitting we can think both the
prediction error the training prediction
error and the testing prediction error
being equally maximum and quite similar
and this is the case where we notice a
lot of high bias and quite a lot of
variance however as we keep on making
our models more and more complex and our
boundaries more and more complex then
this is the case where we have a very
low training error as we saw before
because it captures so well our data
that when new test data come along we
end up being unable to predict them so
what we're trying to do is find that
sweet spot exactly in the middle this
optimum case where we avoid overfitting
and under fitting and the way to do that
is by applying validation so this is
probably one of the most crucial things
in machine learning how to select the
proper validation for your model and
this is something that is very data
dependent as well so the first and
simplest technique to use is the holdout
technique where if we consider that
we're starting from this matrix X we
randomly split our data let's say using
a ratio so one-third for our test data
and the remaining two-thirds for a
training data set and this will lead us
to two independent data data sets so our
trained data set and our test data set
by doing so we leave the test data set
completely side of the whole training
process so it acts as if we have a new
data set coming in and what we're trying
to do is train our model and test and
test its generalization performance
using our test data set however because
this plate is completely random
completely a chance we expect it to
diverse at a time so it may lead to high
variance so you can imagine that you may
be extremely lucky and have all your
best data in your test data set or you
may be extremely unlucky so this is
again where you may fall under the
illusion that your models performing
extremely well because you have a really
good result however if you try a
different split will it be as good or
not another very popular technique in
this case that I think most of you
should be familiar with is the K fold
cross-validation and in this case we
split our data into K different subsets
so for instance if I were to consider
three different cases each time I would
remove a sub set aside and would act as
my test data set and the remaining
subsets would be my training data set by
doing so we reduce the bias and
depending on how many splits you're
going to use this may often lead to
cases of high variance the beauty with
this technique is that all the results
from the independent iterations are
averaged so you can have a more robust
than a more accurate result out of your
validation technique special case of k
for k cross vacaville cross-validation
is the live one address validation where
you live one sample at a time outside so
we can say that each time a single row
is left aside and this is an almost
unbiased technique however because you
leave one sample at a time and it may be
a really good sample to predict or very
low simple to predict this may leave two
cases of high variance and as you can
imagine this is something that's
extremely computational in text intense
it takes a lot of time and a lot of
resources to do so and especially for
big data set is not a very advisable
technique to use finally bootstrapping
is something that is extremely helpful
when it comes to working with really
small data in this case if we were to
start from end number of samples so for
instance examples we tend to end up with
a training data set that contains the
same number of samples but the idea is
that you randomly choose samples out of
your original matrix with replacement so
you pseudo-random
is your data in a way and that's
something very popular for those of you
who would like to work with random
forests this is something that is
extremely useful to know by doing so the
probability of leaving something aside
so every test data set that is not
selected in this replacement process is
considered a test data set in this case
and by doing so we lower both the
variance and the bias so it's kind of an
optimized technique to use it's more
robust than the others however as you
can imagine it's computationally
expensive to do so now the performance
of a particular classification model is
highly dependent if not solely dependent
on the parameters of a particular model
and each one of the classification
models that we're going to use later
today contain a combination of
parameters that need to be tuned or
tweaked and the way that we need to tune
this parameter so you can go around and
provide values one by one and play with
your model but of course this is not a
very nice process so we need to automate
this process so what we tend to do is
combine the validation techniques that
we learned now and try to work together
towards building a parameter selection
so quite a common technique to do is do
use this three-way split where again you
live one test set aside because this is
again how you would like to see them
performance the overall performance of
your model the generalized performance
and what you tend to do is internally
use another validation technique even
one of the ones we've learned before and
will see different cases in our notebook
so you use internally different
validation techniques in order to create
some pseudo test cases and for each
combination of parameters that you have
fed into your model you're trying to see
its performance so based on the
performance that you get out of it you
select the optimal combination of hyper
parameters so if we were to consider
like a careful Chris validation between
for each combination of hyper parameters
you would average the
accuracy and end up with the best
combination but don't worry because we
get to sit in practice later on this is
just the theory behind it finally last
type of model which again is highly
connected to the validation techniques
we covered is the ensemble models and
this contains a lot of multiple
independently trained pseudo models
which are fused into a single model if
you like a supermodel so in a case of
random forests this would be several
independent trees that create a forest
or in as we were joking sometimes
imagine that you have a lot of different
supermodels like Kate Moss and I don't
know anomie candle whichever one you
like and you take characteristics of
each and every one of them all their
good characteristics to move towards
making the ultimate supermodel so this
is the idea rather than having let's say
one very optimistic or one very
pessimistic model you take a hundred of
them and by averaging them out by using
some sort of averaging weather
statistical averaging or majority vote
or some type of waiting such as boosting
you can create this super model and make
sure that the accuracy that the
performance in this case is far more
robust than using just a random model so
it would sum up in a way something like
this so you start from your initial
matrix you do this initial split and
internally what we're trying to achieve
is optimize these parameters and come up
with our optimized decision boundary or
optimize model and finally the test said
that has been left us outside the whole
testing process this is where it comes
in we predict that if you will too if
you were to build an ensemble model in
this case you would repeat this
procedure a hundred times and averaged
out the performance in this case the
accuracy at this point will swap to our
ipython notebooks and try to build
something in practice
alright so the first step we need to
load in our required libraries so please
do let us know if anyone has any issues
with any other libraries place your
hands up if you have any questions
please place your hands up again yes
sorry that's the one okay I'll leave the
github URL a little bit on
watch it yep that's it that I have a
long time series data in my case long by
samples or by features or by both three
years of data okay and I know that I
can't split that two for example two
years and one year for testing so I did
it thought of it what would be a good
practice even though I'm not sure
because I am disgusted with anyone
really have no real opinion so what I
did is I took moving window example
sliding window two months of data and
split that period 6040 or 7031 then I
was retraining the model and retesting
by moving the window yeah right what i
had so i had multiple questions to
answer what is the optimal historical
training life yeah mm-hmm so can we get
back to that after the tutorial because
that's very time serious specific so
it's like very problem specific and I
don't want to run out of time because a
lot of people want to go and drink but
but we'll get back to that I'll come
right over when I hand it to shine and
answer your question so let's just try
to cover like what we have here and
bring everyone up to speed without but I
will get back to that one and answer
your questions okay so anyone had any
issues importing the libraries at this
point nope okay so as a first approach
we're going to try and load our data in
and of course during a live demo
something is not working for me don't
you love the pleasures of a live demo
okay so at this stage you should have
imported your breast cancer data from
the provided CSV file and if we use the
head command you can see some sort of
the first background of our data and can
see what each one of the features
contain
so it's only a subset in this case of
the first five rows now in order to work
with this I could learn library and any
classification techniques provided in
Python we need to convert our data into
an umpire ray and as I mentioned before
it's common practice in machine learning
to split our data into our input matrix
in this case represented by X and the
associated class vector because we want
to keep this information independently
so this is where I said before that data
scientists need to decipher every time
this information and you need to be able
to go through your file and detect where
this information is lying and make sure
to split the two apart so it's good
practice to also print the
dimensionality of your data because you
never know during the import that you
know when something may go wrong and you
end up building something crazy and then
afterwards you're just trying to figure
out what went wrong in the first place
so at this point if we plot the
dimensionality of our data we expect to
see 569 rose everything that's before
the coma is representing the rose and 30
features and similarly we expect to see
569 elements in our associated class
vector now a good good practice is also
to have a look at the distribution
within each class so we have loaded our
data but we would like to see how many
samples we have in each particular class
and why is that important because if we
have any sort of imbalances and a
majority class that is highly
represented over a minority class then
our models later on may be biased to
this particular class so it's something
to investigate far in advance because
there may be something that needs to be
applied later on such as weights as
we're going to see now in our current
data set the wine labels are categorical
so they contain both discrete they can
take any of discrete values and widths I
could learn we need to convert them into
numeric values so
we fit a label encoder in this case and
transform our data into intern American
values yes so that is applied on the
Associated class labels so that is a
vector in this case and has five that's
okay it's not a problem so so yeah that
contains so if we were to print up
before it would contain values of B and
M and have 569 elements and after the
after we fit the label encoder it will
contain zero and one so we're mapping it
to numeric values everyone cool so far
yeah cool so usually when we're dealing
with machine learning when we're working
with machine learning we don't just take
our data and just dump it into a model
it's not as easy as plug-and-play who I
mean we would have loved that but it's
hard labor the case so it's also very
good practice to apply some sort of a
pre-processing technique and by
pre-processing you may mean mean
centering or auto scaling or range
scaling or some sort of scaling maybe
log transformations unfortunately there
is not a purse a command to use in this
case a purse a technique so it's very
data dependent and you have to go in
back to your particular problem and see
what is more fit but it's very good
practice to apply some sort of scaling
and the reason behind that is if you
have some dominant variables that expand
over wide ranges versus other variables
it may be because that your models again
once more our bias towards this
particular value variables so in this
case what we're going to do is start by
auto scaling our data because particular
models especially such as svms tend to
perform far better when scaling has been
applied so at this point again our
matrix does not change in dimension in
dimensions so we just change the
contents of our matrix
by centering per column and then
applying a scaling factor in each one of
the columns which is the standard
deviation now as I mentioned before good
practice at this point is to use some
sort of scatter plot and plot one class
against another and see how well how
well we can separate the one class
against the other are my samples
overlapping or are they far apart from
one another and we can see in this case
that most probably I mean these are just
two features that we have just randomly
selected out of the 30 that we have
imported but in this case we can see
some sort of overlap so potentially more
complex models may be worse to
investigate rather than linear models
finally the distribution plot so the
histogram is wasted before we can have a
look and feel of the frequency for each
particular class so we can see again
that the malignant cases are spreading
over larger not a numerical values than
the Pennines everyone good so far any
questions nope cool okay so as a next
step what we're going to do is apply our
first validation techniques oh good
common practice we never ever take our
whole X matrix unless you have for sure
a new data set someone in your lab or
someone who is willing to provide you
with a new data set what unless you have
someone who can provide it with this
type of data then you're one of the
lucky ones if you don't it's common
practice to split our data into a
training data set and a test data set as
we mentioned before so as a first
approach we're going to apply the
holdout method and split our data using
again like thirty percent of our data
will belong in our test set and seven
percent of our data will belong in our
training set so if we were to print the
dimensions in this case we can see
exactly that
so far so good yes so that was me
neglecting to cover something so with a
holdout approach there is a special case
which is called the stratified hold out
and don't so in this case instead of
just splitting into let's say thirty
percent of our samples go into the test
case in which case as you will spot it
you may end up not having a
representative of a particular class
because it's selected at random so you
may end up only with samples from one
particular class however with stratified
hold out what you do is you select one
third of the samples but one third from
each particular class so you make sure
that the distribution of your data as
you had it in your initial matrix is
preserved in your test data set so in
this case this is one of the techniques
you can use you can use a holdout or you
can use a stratified hold out its data
dependent you may have like a perfectly
balanced data set or or not so it's down
to you we just teach you the tips and
tricks and then you go back to your data
and see what works for the best yeah
Matt will spot it
okay so the first model that we will
construct at this point is the k-nearest
neighbors and this is like a very
simplistic model it's the most emplace
the God of all the models and the
intuition behind it is that you have a
new data set coming in in this case the
X data set and let us assume that we
would like to investigate the six
nearest neighbors as in this case so it
finds the six nearest neighbors using
the euclidean distance it uses some sort
of metric in this case it uses the
euclidean distance so it's both the
neighbors that are the closest to the
particular sample and then it takes a
majority vote of these six cases so if I
had in this case one two three four red
samples and one green sample what do you
think my new data said what was going to
be any takers any guesses okay voting
for vs 1 i'm sure some of you may bet
like for football or something so i'm
sure you know the answer come on no okay
hbu is not taking into consideration so
we're just following the arrows so we
have okay let's do it again let's try
your mouths so you have four cases of
red in one case of green so what would
make our new sample what would our new
sample be in this case yay so well done
hands of tea so exactly this algorithm
is very simple because it looks at the
nearest neighbors and rather than
building a decision boundary such as the
ones that we're going to see later on in
a more advanced modeled it just goes to
the neighbors and say okay so how many
female versus male do I have next to me
or how many green vs red do I have next
to me so this is one way to do that so
we pre specify pre-define a particular
number for the cane and number of
neighbors we would like to investigate
another one is to use the radius so we
define a particular region and we see
how many neighbors fall into that
particular region so these are the two
cases however one of the peculiarities
something to
think about when working with canners
neighbors is that you don't want to take
a number such as two or four so what
would happen if I had like one red
versus one green it's a tie the
algorithm doesn't know how to decide one
against another so in this case it's
good practice to always go with an odd
number okay so at this point and give
you a few minutes to work on the next
part of the exercise and we can all
discuss it together so trying scroll
through the k-nearest neighbors example
don't go too far go okay with the SMS
and stuff so just try and play around
and see what you think you're gonna work
in Paris again if you want to it's good
to discuss with a body with a probe body
together so try and play around and and
see what you get out of the out of the
decision boundaries okay so we're going
to start by playing around just two
random k values for canine model for
those of you that didn't have the time
to finish up don't worry you can follow
my lead as I speak so we're going to
start by experimenting with two random
values so I just chose for instance
three neighbors which is quite small and
also a hundred neighbors which is quite
large and you can see in this case that
are 100 neighbors still perform as well
as expected so a good idea would be to
visualize these boundaries so this
separation and see what we end up what
we end up with so in this case when
we're working with a very small number
of K so when we're looking into just a
small subset of neighbors close to our
samples we can see that again we have a
lot of patches a lot of boundaries that
surround independent samples and a lot
of creases in our model it's definitely
not linear in this case and those
probably bit that may give us an idea
that it tends towards some sort of
overfitting on the other side if we
compare and see the decision boundaries
created by
a hundred nearest neighbors when we take
a far larger subset of our data then we
say that our boundaries tend towards
linearity so in this case the slightly
lower accuracy that we got it may be the
case of under fitting because our model
is not as advanced as it should have
been as complex as it should have been
to be able two distinct the data from
one another the categories from one
another and we can see that by using
this this boundary something else to
take into consideration and this brings
me back to again some sort of waiting
you may want to to investigate in order
to improve the performance of your model
so with key nearest neighbors another
parameter that we can tune if we want to
ease the weights so before we used
uniform weights which is the default
value and you can also in in this case
investigate weights equals distance
which means that we want the closest
neighbors to give more of an input in
our model than the ones that are further
away and in this case if we try and see
the accuracy doesn't really improve at
least it doesn't prove it for that
particular number of neighbors but this
is not the most automated approach we
would have hoped for so rather than
trying of course independent values we
would like to come up with something
more clever in which way we investigate
simultaneously both the different cases
so uniform versus distance and also the
number of nearest neighbors again
remember that in this case we have we're
skipping the even numbers and we take
only the odd numbers into consideration
for our models and we can see that after
a particular number i would say around
50 or so we see a huge decrease in the
performance of our model so of course
you can expect at this point that either
our boundaries are too complex or
they're not complex enough to feed our
data so well so this is something worth
investigating try different parameters
so that's the whole idea behind me
machine learning if you don't choose
your
parameters correctly you may deplete
something that is either too great or
too bad and you won't be able to know it
unless you compare it and have a look on
different types of values different
types of parameters so this is one way
that you could go around that you can
choose to graph it in this way by
increasing the number of K one at a time
and see what you can come up with
however another approach that is quite
common to use for many different models
is the tuning with some sort of grid
search so you provide your model with a
grid search or a combination of
parameters you would like to investigate
simultaneously so for instance I may
want the combination of this number of
neighbors and these type of weights you
throw it into these parameters and the
grid search command so this one here
grid search with cross validation and it
fixes all the combination for one by one
the parameter so it takes a combination
of the parameters together and there it
is like as we said before what's going
on behind this behind the scenes is that
it uses some sort of validation in this
case it's a grid search with
cross-validation to investigate which
combination of parameters is going to be
more fit for our model so if we were to
plot that we can think of each box as
being cross-validated with a particular
combination of hyper parameters so
that's the whole idea behind using a
heat map in this case so consider each
one of the boxes in our heat map being a
completely independent model that has
been trained and tested using a
particular combination of hyper
parameters so by applying this grid
search and using internally
cross-validation it can return to you
the optimal combination of hyper
parameters and this is the kind of hyper
parameter combination you would later on
like to use to test to finally test your
model using the independent test set
that we have kept the side any questions
so far maybe so no everyone good cool so
in this case um our model didn't
actually improve so much it actually
didn't improve at all for the canine
classifier but maybe a different model
can tell us something different so that
can be a good indication to see can I do
better in every computer science
question that we have to answer any
machine learning one there's always a
question can I do better can I speed
more can I can it perform better so grid
search is one approach that you can
choose to use but of course it's quite a
computationally intense technique so
with I could learn there's also the
randomized search cross-validation with
whereby we're just not going to
exhaustively through one by one the
combinations but it actually randomly
picks different hyper parameters so if
you were to plot that you would see
again the performance for each one of
these parameters and you can determine
the number of parameters that in this
case the number of neighbors that
perform better than others ok cool it's
at this point we saw better keen and
classifier performed at a clip
adequately but maybe we can do better so
as a next step we can investigate one of
the most powerful and personally my
favorite machine learning technique
machine learnings our machine learning
support machine learning so sorry
support vector machines are quite
powerful in state-of-the-art machine
learning techniques and they're
considered black boxes and the reason
behind that is that their implementation
is so complex that we would like to
avoid learning more about how it works
and just use it as a black box you feed
your data in and you get some sort of
output out and the majority of the data
scientists out there this is how they
use support vector machines now this is
really good from one point of view
because it makes our life easier not
doing the trouble and understanding the
geometry behind and all the rules behind
support vector machines but when it's
time to tune its hyper parameters this
especially this technique is very tricky
and very prone to overfitting so the
idea behind support vector machines is
that again it decides it wants to build
a decision boundary that has a low
generalization error or a maximum
generalization accuracy but the whole
idea is that it's different because
we're trying to maximize the distance
also called as margin between the
nearest points of the two classes these
nearest points of the two classes are
what is called support vectors and the
difference of support vector machines
versus any other machine learning
technique that constructs a boundary is
that it does not take all the samples at
once to find the distance towards this
boundary and and fine how to maximize
this margin but it only takes the
nearest points between the classes so we
can imagine that we can split this
region using as many help as many planes
as many lines as possible but we're
trying to find the optimal line or the
optimal hyperplane that accurately
separates these two regions by using
only this subset of samples that are
closely found to one another these are
the ones that are termed support vectors
now to begin with support vector
machines did not allowed any
misclassifications so there were hard
margin svms but one of the parameters
that was later introduced one of the
hyper parameters in SVM's is the cost or
the penalty factor whereby we allow some
training misclassifications as a way of
increasing our generalization
performance in this case as our cost
increases then the misclassifications
become more and more significant and
email and most probably will
each to overfitting now what happens in
the case where our input space is far
too complex to fit a straight line and
accurately separate the two classes in
this case we will need to step up
towards a non linear classification and
a nonlinear boundary but how do we do
that this is where the most powerful
attribute of support support vector
machines kicks in this is the kernel
trick so we start from a non-separable
input space and then we have a very cool
powerful a kernel function doing
everything for us and it projects the
data into a higher dimensional space
this space can be possibly infinite
dimensional and this is where
overfitting maybe also it may be a case
that overfitting may actually happen and
in this feature space we're trying to
find again an optimal linear linear
hyperplane that tries to separate the
two classes from one another so we can
see in this case that if we project into
a three-dimensional space there is a
hyperplane that smoothly cuts in between
the two cases where as an input space
that's impossible to do so and by back
projecting this optimal linear
hyperplane into our original space this
is when we end up with a nonlinear
boundary so ideally we end up with
something that looks like this now the
RBF svms are the most popular out of all
the kernels out of all the off-the-shelf
kernels that support vector machines
provide to us and in this case in
addition to the cost parameter which is
common across all these VMs there is
also the gamma parameter and this
parameter determines the degree of
non-linearity of our models so we can
see that by going to low with a gamma
parameter we have linear boundaries
which may prove to be under fitting our
data and by going to far as gamma
increases then the decision boundaries
become more and more nonlinear
we have a lot of sharp peaks a lot of
independently individually surrounded
samples and some spiky functions so
again this is a case of overfitting our
data and SVM's are one of the most
powerful techniques but again account
stressed enough that if you don't apply
proper validation you may end up with an
over fit in your data so once more one
of the most common ways to tune our
support vector machines is to use some
sort of grid search including validation
so again we can consider a combination
of Heather parameters of cost and gamma
we usually go exponentially and check
these parameters and and yeah we can
consider that each one of these boxes
contain some sort of validations for
instance you can have internally careful
cross validation or bootstrapping in
every one of these boxes this will give
you a good indication of where we can
find a good parameter region so what
combination of hyper parameters are
going to make our model more robust and
give us the best generalization
performance if you choose to do that you
can also follow it with an extensive
grid search so a finer tuning within
that particular region of good
parameters if not and grid search is a
perfectly simple very simplistic
approach to follow but it is very
time-consuming so sometimes using a
heuristic can be an alternative but it's
over the first step to try with some
simple like grid search and see what
that gives you before moving to more
complex and heuristic approaches so at
this point let's go back to our ipython
notebook and play around with us fans so
i'll give you like 10 * 10 minutes to
take your time and play around with the
SVM so we can discuss the results
okay so how is everyone doing good okay
so as we said before we can start by
investigating linner as fans because
it's always good practice to start from
a simple linear model even if you know
that your data is most probably likely
to be nonlinear is there with good
practice to start with a simplistic
linear model and work your way towards
something more complex because if you
talk a complex model all in one go you
may come across different situations
such as the imbalance or the cross
validation of the any other thing that
you may want to investigate using a far
simpler model before you also throw in
the kind of tuning of the hyper
parameters over a particular complex
model so if we start in this case by
using our linear SVM sand in particular
use the default values given to us for
the cost function so remember our linear
SVM are dependent on the cost parameter
in this case so again we train our data
using our train data set and we test it
with our independent test data set and
we can get a fairly good result out of
svm so we can save it as viens performed
far better than our kin and model but
can we do better again the question that
we keep asking ourselves since we got a
hint of non-linearity before in our data
can we do better it's a nonlinear model
going to give me a better performance
than a linear one so if i were to
investigate at this point a nonlinear
model and use the default values we can
see that it actually performs quite well
it performs equally well as a linear
model but in this case we're taking into
consideration our default parameters and
this is one of the biggest mistakes you
wouldn't necessarily take the default
parameters of our model you would
experiment with the hyper parameters and
see how far you could go to have a
better model but without overfitting
once more in order to achieve that we
would like to investigate our grid
search
so we would like to have great search
perform with cross validation for a
predefined range range of hyper
parameters so predefined the range that
I would like my my hyper parameters to
take and these are the hyper parameters
that I will feed into the pseudo models
I'm creating in each grid search
iteration so again you can choose to
plot these results by using a heat map
again an indication of a good parameter
region so we can see that in this region
our model most probably has our pseudo
models returned back to us and reported
that these are very good regions very
good combinations of hyper parameters
now once I retrieve the best hyper
parameters the best parameter for cost
and the purse parameter for gamma out of
my cross-validated models we can see
that once we apply these parameters to
our models no surprise we get a
ninety-nine percent of our data being
correctly classified so you can see of
course in this case our models performed
to begin with quite well so we started
from a 96 move to 98 but we can see that
there is some improvement by applying
some tuned pipe parameters in our model
just something to bear in mind in the
case in particular of svms and grid
search validation is that when we when
you do this grid search first of all
it's a very simplistic
easy-to-understand approach very
intuitive but it's quite exhaustive and
time-consuming and it takes a lot of
combinations and a lot of time
computational time and something else to
taking into consideration is that we're
looking into a particular region and
within this region you may have one time
peak that may be the best parameters
possible for our model but with a grid
search unfortunately you can't tune it
down so thoroughly so possibly a
heuristic another implementation in this
case some sort of an optimization
algorithm could be more fit and again I
would say always start by using
simplistic techniques such as
cross-validation and grid search before
you move on
something far more advanced so if you
have any questions about other types of
her specs and things you could use I'm
more than happy afterwards to answer all
your questions for now pass your own to
she shed and she's going to talk you
through logistic regression and some
neural Nets yep this is just going to be
a really quick one but erm it's just so
we cover like some breaths as well so
basically i mean the intuition behind
logistic regression is very similar to
linear regression so you can see it
really as an extension of linear
regression what you'll put what you're
actually outputting is a probability
though so you're you're outputting a
value between 0 and 1 and then you're
using that to make some sort of decision
so you can see just as in linear
regression you have coefficients before
each of the terms you have weights or
parameters before which of the terms
which are your features with logistic
regression and then you combine them and
using some sort of function that adds
them aggregates them usually adding them
and then you have another function that
determines how you make decision so
sometimes it's an absolute threshold
sometimes it's like you use the the
outcome that's the most likely out of
the whole range of outcomes and that's
what you use to basically base your
prediction on so that's the intuition
behind logistic regression and the
important thing about that is that
basically it's still based on a linear
function is based on it's basically an
extension of linear regression that also
means that the decision boundary is also
linear so as you can see from here the
separation between two classes is a
sharp line in terms of hyper parameters
so the main ones that get tuned are the
penalty function so what you're using to
basically determine
how much something's deviating so that
the two penalty functions are these
squares and absolute deviations so
that's a hyper parameter that often gets
tested so absolute deviation is like the
absolute value with which it deviates
from the prediction whereas least
squares is taking the square values so
just very quickly on on your net so yeah
you can see it both ways so on their
hand you can see logistic regression is
really just a simple one layer your net
and and when you link that you basically
get a multi-layer neural network so the
thing with the neural network is that
you have this hit hidden layer one or
more hidden layers and that's the part
that gives you the non-linearity so if
you just had a single that it would be
just like logistic regression but it's
the lawn linearity you can see is lying
in here unfortunately just like with
svms that's also what makes it a tricky
model to understand and to tune so
actually that that is an issue with
neural Nets so there were actually even
if you were just going to do hyper fram
to search just by looking at the
architecture of the neural net that
already if you think about how you can
explore that architecture that's already
a huge parameter space and that's why
it's a very using in terms of the
optimization and the reliability if you
like of neural Nets that's kind of one
criticism that they've received and even
though they're really hot at the moment
because also because of the
non-linearity they're highly general and
they can fit very complex models so
there's something to bear in mind you
have to trade off
like this sort of black box ishness
which some people may be more or less
comfortable with with the complexity of
the model so as you can see like here
for example this is like a lot more
nonlinear decision surface and it can
get a lot more I mean I'll show you in a
minute with the ipython notebook you
could get some very intricate you know
decision boundaries so going over
fitting is it is a big problem so now if
we switch to the employed Python
notebook now oh I may need your because
it's the laptop so so chrome
so if I if I leave you some time to play
as well I think oh it's ten minutes away
so we'll allowed five minutes and I can
talk you through it how's everyone doing
okay I'll just run through this very
quickly then so we can go and have a
drink so basically again if we use the
default values for logistic regression
which is built into scikit-learn we get
pretty good accuracy I have to say
working with this data set was
frustrating because it was actually
quite an easy data set so as you can see
how a curiosity scores are pretty high
but we always want to do better so this
is what the default values you get point
98 accuracy with this linear decision
plot and just to have a look at the
default values you can see that in
scikit-learn the the penalization is l2
and then the cost is this is the
regularization rate so something that
Elena talked about as well that's
another hyper parameter that you can
tune in logistic regression so you get
that with the default values and then
doing a grid search over these ranges
you end up with so the cost of north
point 5 and the penalty l2 gives you the
best results which is point 99 accuracy
again improving so just to see that on
the plot again so you'll see this is
quite interesting as well because you
saw before with the lanus plot some of
the with the heat map the best
performances were together but here it
seems that you've got kind of hot
regions in different areas so that's an
interesting feature as well to look out
for and then with neural networks again
so this sort of these values give you
point nine seven and then if you play
run again if you look at this decision
plot very strange shapes emerging here
depending on what you feed in like this
one with a three layer architecture
gives you this again doing there the
grid search over these ranges can
explore that end up with this game it's
it's interesting the shape of the heat
map as well so yeah that's kind of endor
session because I got a wave before and
if you have any more questions just feel
free to ask and I just want to show you
our last slide because I lay there she
was yeah it's a parting thought I think
there we go never ever trust your moment
to make sure that there is that's the
bottom story so a few things to just
wrap up first of all you need to give a
high five to your parody to your
programming better because you did so
amazingly well and I don't want to keep
you away from drinks I know what python
is just can do for a drink and just a
few things for those of you who have
asked about access to all the code it's
gonna be there we want to remove it it's
on the Cambridge coding github page you
can either copy the link at the moment
or you can find it through the abstract
of our talk online throughout the PI
data I'll just leave it a little bit for
you to play around with I keep in mind
you have a look in our Cambridge coding
website as well because there's a lot of
exciting workshops coming up in Python
so for instance a lot of regression
workshops and neural net specific
workshops on supervised learning
technique and others or we can tune down
and have a private session depending on
your needs if you want to and last but
not least if you want to come and grab
us for questions or anything machine
learning related or if you want to
subscribe to our mailing list please let
us know and there are some Flyers as
well shane has some flyers over there
but thank you all so much thank you